when you think of alligators the first
words that come to mind probably aren't
tender loving and maternal this video
may make you think again here in the
Everglades a mother alligator listens to
the calls of her young as they hatch
predators like this Scott just love
delectable helpless hatchling Gators the
skunk hones in on the hatchlings cries
Gator mom is having none of us
she excavates her newborns and
transports them to the swamp in her jaws
of death
now the Gator babies are with mom
unlike Crocs the Gator toddlers stay
close to mom for the first year and for
good reason because death lurks just
about everywhere this hungry great blue
heron is on the prowl for a meal this
gator baby hides under a lily pad and
calls for his mother a baby Gator is one
thing but a full-grown Gator is a whole
different deal
mom's right there with her babies and
she saves the day until dawn this little
guy is an easy target for a snapping
turtle
fortunately the turtle just isn't hungry
but one of the babies isn't so lucky
he's way too far from mom and way too
oblivious to the danger that's all
around him
he tries hard to escape but this Gator
will never again know the shelter of its
mother's ferocious but gentle jaws now
come on
say the words with me tender gentle
loving maternal